[Music]
in 2009 the new teacher project sparked
a wave of reform when reported that less
than 1% of teachers were rated
unsatisfactory even in school systems
with the bismil student outcomes urged
on by Washington more than 30 states
adopted new teacher evaluation systems
good idea but a case study in how
well-intentioned reforms can turn into
clumsy mandates principals in Nevada for
example now estimate they spend 150
hours or 19 work days a year filling out
required paperwork that's simply
rehashes what they'd already observed in
classrooms recorded on paper and
discussed with teachers it wastes time
and that's a recipe for chasing away the
kind of great school leaders we need and
for all of the paper shuffling still
just one to two percent of teachers are
rated unsatisfactory look teachers
absolutely need to be evaluated more
rigorously the way to do this though is
not by imposing paper burdens it's by
giving a school leaders more authority
leeway and autonomy and then holding
them responsible for what they do with
it how do you think we should hold
educators accountable let us know in
your comments also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI